[Music]
we got our hands on and played with the
Xbox one x microsoft says it's their
smallest console yet an in person it
looks a lot like a black xbox one s the
ports on the back included power HDMI
out HDMI in two USB 3.0 ports IR out
spit off' and Gigabit Ethernet
there are also vents on both sides of
the console the Xbox one X features a
physical power button on the front along
with another USB 3.0 port Microsoft also
provided an inside look at the system
showing off all the layers of the
console will be past the top of the case
in the chassis here is a look at the
blu-ray optical drive which is capable
of playing 4k HDR movies not even Sony's
high-end ps4 Pro has a blu-ray drive
this is the console CPU fan underneath
the fan there's a vapor chamber cooler
heatsink which contains a vacuum-sealed
liquid that transforms the gas at high
temperatures to help keep the console
cool like the Xbox one s before the One
X features an integrated power supply
this is the One X's mother blue which
houses the consoles eight core AMD SOC
and integrated GPU it's capable of
delivering six teraflops of performance
the black little rectangles surrounding
the chip are the 12 gigabytes of gddr5
memory
next up is the consoles 2.5 inch one
terabyte hard drive we also get a chance
to play Forza Motorsport 7 at 4k
using the Xbox one X's development kit
game was running at 60 frames per second
and turn 10 studios told us that it's
running at approximately high to ultra
peace equivalent settings the game
looked great though if we're nitpicking
we did notice some slight jaggies on
power lines in the background not only
will the Xbox one X run at a higher
resolution than its Xbox one counterpart
the developer tells us that it's able to
slightly crank up some additional
graphical bells and whistles so that was
our first look at the Xbox one
you like this video and give it a thumbs
up for more gaming hardware coverage
subscribe to us on YouTube thank you for
watching